here with reaction to all this New York
congresswoman Elise Stefanik by the way
she comes out of these hearings of my
mind a new star of the Republican House
of Representatives guys always been a
star Minority Whip Steve Scalise
congresswoman let us begin with you I've
watched you in this hearings have not
known a lot about you I gotta say
phenomenal job and thank you for all
you've done thank you I've just focused
on the facts and it is clear as every
day that goes by that Democrats case for
impeachment is crumbling Adam Schiff has
been an abject failure and again the
facts remain the same Ukraine got the
aid there was no quid pro quo and there
was no investigation into the Biden's in
fact the only investigations into burr
yzma was under the Obama administration
but yet Adam Schiff continues his regime
of secrecy and because I've been such an
outspoken advocate for the facts I have
been attacked by the Hollywood left who
have dumped millions into supporting my
far left Democratic opponent which is
why I need the American people to step
up donate at fight shift calm to help me
speak for the American people in my
district good for you for standing out
and you know what any time you step out
you take a risk congressman Scalise I
said this to Kevin McCarthy last night
I'll say it to you being part of the
House Republican leadership I don't
think I've ever and I've been very
critical of Republicans you've heard me
when you guys don't have a backbone and
you're weak and you're visionless and
feckless and I think I'm pretty loud in
my criticism this was the Republicans at
their best this week and they did their
job and they were prepared and they they
fought it out and they won yes Sean I
can't be more proud of our members of
the Intelligence Committee who asked the
tough questions who focused on the facts
that's really what this has been about
from the beginning for us for Adam
Schiff it was about impeaching the
president and had nothing to do with
facts and then of course you look and he
vetoed our witnesses he shut us out of
those hearings you know when I brought a
few of my colleagues Matt gates and
others down to the shifts giftware we
were trying to just find out what was
going on
he literally ran out of the back room
with the witness you know what has he
been trying to hide I think we see now
he's got no case there literally is no
evidence that there was any collusion I
thought as so many of our members look
what at least did heroic Lee asking
tough questions that makes her a target
of the left you know that that fight
shift calm sight she's talking about I
think people are fed up with the
bullying the intimidation that's coming
from the left you know the people that
are claiming quid pro quo they're the
ones who are out there frankly that it
started with Joe Biden he was the
original quid pro quo where he literally
said I'm leaving in six hours with the
billion dollars of EUR and my taxpayer
money if they don't fire the guy looking
into his son and they fired the guy and
then Joe Biden wants to ride off into
the sunset and impeach Donald Trump for
that there is no impeachable offense
every witness every star Democrat
witness made clear they saw nothing even
the hearsay
not one person Sandlin was there gonna
be their star yesterday and Mike Turner
I thought asked it best yesterday when
he said has anybody on the planet drawn
a connection between President Trump
asking for money in exchange for
investigations and not one person the
Ukrainian foreign minister said it never
happened they got all money I mean have
your star appeasement the only witness
so sullen yesterday and he said you know
this is just my opinion conjecture you
ever talked to the president yes what
did you you asked the president what
what does he want he says nothing I
don't want to quid pro quo I want him to
do the right thing
congresswoman you had a very well now
famous I guess exchange with the
congenital liar running the ship show
and it was interesting because you were
calling for fundamental fairness now
Republicans have have asked for
witnesses to come forward they have not
been granted that from up high on shift
mountain that's correct and that's how
unfair this process has been I was the
first member of Congress to ask the
question when did Adam Schiff talk to
the whistleblower and I was ridiculed by
the mainstream media but it turns out
that it is clear that there was
coordination between the whistleblower
and Adam Schiff Democratic staff and the
one witness that Adam Schiff won't call
is the whistleblower who started off
this entire impeachment process in
addition Adam Schiff refuses to call
hunter Biden and every single witness
that was asked the question is there a
potential appearance of a conflict of
interest it means zero experience hunter
the one that had no experience that was
paid millions whose dad when he found
out it was being investigated shook down
Ukraine and said you're not getting a
billion dollars unless you fire the guy
investigating my zero experience son
paid millions that 100 and as though is
the witness that Adam Schiff will not
call and it's certainly when it comes to
my district my constituents want to hear
from hunter Biden but the good news
Shawn is despite this incredibly
partisan unfair process Republicans
control the Senate and I am hopeful that
they will run a fair process call Adam
Schiff call the whistleblower and call
hunter Biden to actually get to the
facts and really focus on the corruption
in 348 days the American people get the
final say and if well Steve Scalise
becomes the what would you be then the
House Majority Leader then I guess that
could happen couldn't it thank you both
congressman Scalise congresswoman
Stefanik thank you very much